yeah this has been such a fun
conversation cause you're quite answers
I want to know more about the effect of
like five five Amir dmt on what the
research has been but we'll have to do
that again yeah we've we've modelled
some interesting states I don't think
anybody has done the type of data that
we've done I think even Tim was
surprised when I said that but we what
we've what we've pulled out and like on
the my computer I mean we've we've got
the modelling of what what happens we
have the ten minute baseline on several
of the videos that we animated using is
is plug in when you see the components
firing with information Granger
causality and then you see it's 600
seconds which is 10 minutes you see the
hit right the person takes the
inhalation within 20 milliseconds you
see this radical shifting transformation
of active inhibition that's what we were
talking about when you walked up that
the brain is actively inhibiting itself
and that is astounding to me it's
actively not communicating and in that
silence something wonderful emerges yeah
so I'll have to talk what do you think
is a wonderful thing that emerges in
that silence I think the magic of
consciousness is in the interplay
between empty spaces so Pam mentioned
that the magic of music I think is the
space between notes uh-huh I think
there's there's a very deep truth in
that because we saw 12 I was explaining
to him I said we saw the power drop out
across the cortex that makes no sense
intuitively you're going oh my god I'm
visiting this I mean that she's teaching
me about my mother I'm realizing this
I'm realizing that I'm throwing up I am
I'm hearing the sound of creation I'm
witnessing infinite fractals of
iterations of spirits before me but yeah
that's what's going on in there but I'm
telling you out here which is like
it's a tremendous drop in power as
astounding and that's why I mentioned
that I was wondering my kind of secret
theory is is this an example of
stochastic resonance which is when you
take a very very faint signal and how
you amplify it is that you flood it with
random noise think about it if you take
a very very faint signal like a very
degraded photograph and convert it
digitally you amplify and of noise
you're your random 5 Hertz it's going to
enhance the existing 5 Hertz and make it
come up more you see what I'm saying
and it's a it's a tool used I think in
Photoshop even or the NSA definitely
uses it to extract license numbers but
you take a faint signal Venice or flood
it with random noise you're going to
enhance the inherent signal signal and I
think one of the things that we suspect
least we there's no there's no Royal we
there's no like I'm a part of some
weenus maybe it's just me and me is that
the inherent noise and the brain is
vital to our consciousness the inherent
noise of little tiny things happening I
think in the psychedelic state that
noise is not noise there's inherent
information in there that gets amplified
and gets experienced that's why I think
the secret is or one of the pathways
forward and understanding this stuff and
that could potentially also be an
analogy with our obsessive use of the
technology every time there's a moment
of silence and our lives yeah and so if
we were to not use the technology in
those little moments there that would
give the space for that to come up it's
not that unusual and then just let me
just say this little bit here 1797
William Wordsworth wrote a beautiful
series of poems expostulation and reply
I think it's either 1797 or 1798 and I
don't know they don't have the poem
memorize thinking and I just know what a
little bit of it but his friend comes up
to him in the poem and says dude
aren't you just sitting there wasting
your time by this lake come on you know
go read books man this is where it's all
hat I mean
paraphrasing that but he responds he
says there's something like the I cannot
choose but see the ear cannot choose but
here our bodies will feel what it will
with or against our will so why should I
be seeking when I and wise passiveness
here can learn more of moral and of evil
then all the sages can teach me so that
notion of wise passiveness in attention
or in meditation and listening enables I
think he was spot-on because to me you
know that people like I'm sorry here
your generations all we've invented this
we've got this like you know 1798
William Wordsworth was sitting by a lake
and then wise passiveness feeling the
vibe of what's important and learning
yeah
even Shakespeare hints at this in his
writings I mean when Glouster was
blinded you know and his son said hey
let me help you he's no I have no way
because when I had eyes I could not find
my way or something like that so they
had put it on his eyes out and he was
feeling sorry says no wait I have eyes I
still was lost now that I have no eyes I
know where I'm going so there is
something about wise passiveness about
meditation about silence about and I
think in psychedelics what's happening
is that the practicality of lowering
certain power levels in the brain
emerges a different type of knowing to
emerge